how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
lender where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we're going to talk about one
of our favorite topics and that is of
course the x-men making their Marvel
Cinematic Universe debut we're all
waiting for the x-men to debut and it
looks like they're going to start to
make their appearances starting in phase
four and then come together in an
Avengers like film except only it will
be the x-men film and today we have a
new report about a possible lineup that
Marvel is considering for the x-men in
the MCU and not only that but where some
of the x-men might actually come from so
we'll break it down in this video but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a Hulk from Avengers in-game Funko pop
to enter all you have to do is subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below I pick winners on Mondays so we
all know that the x-men are coming to
the MCU the question is when and also
who are the ones that we're going to see
first well a recent report from Mikey
Sutton named dropped several mutants
that we can expect to see in the MCU
some familiar some not so familiar so
we'll break down what this report said
it says that Marvel Studios is plans for
the x-men are in the earliest stages of
development the mutants are indeed
coming to the MCU and will be introduced
Avenger style and other characters as
films according to Mikey Sutton's inside
sources they are currently looking at
the initial lineup of the x-men to
include Cyclops Marvel Girl Thunderbird
Nightcrawler Sunfire havoc and storm who
is going to be from Wakanda according to
this report Mikey says that Kevin Feige
wants an all-new all-different approach
at least somewhat compared to what Fox
did for so long with the x-men the
president of Marvel Studios is looking
at focusing on the team as a school with
some students joining Professor X on
missions while others still studying and
training essentially a Hogwarts for
mutants now although this is in very
early development and there is no
concrete plans right now no script
written or anything
the next part could be a potential
spoiler so proceed at your own
well the seriousness of what Professor
Xavier school does and what the x-men do
is brought to surface win spoiler alert
thunderbird is killed during a trip to
krakoa
mikey says that no scripts have been
written as of yet there is only
brainstorming and discussions at this
point but this is reportedly where they
are at present time now it's no surprise
that Marvel Studios has already begun
brainstorming on what they plan to do
with the x-men Marvel has the next five
years mapped out on which movies they're
going to do and which characters they're
going to introduce into the MCU and they
have an idea of what they want to do
over the next 10 years as well in fact
Kevin Feige name-dropped
mutants at San Diego comic-con of 2019
so we know that they are definitely
already brainstorming on what to do with
the x-men now in this report there are
three main things that we need to focus
on and the first one is the lineup
Cyclops Marvel Girl Thunderbird
Nightcrawler Sunfire havoc and storm now
it's important to note that these are
not going to be the only x-men
introduced in the MCU at this time in
fact this report does mention Professor
Xavier and his school and if we have his
school in the MCU that means we're going
to have many many different mutants what
this lineup implies is that these are
the characters that are actually going
to make up the x-men team the team that
goes out and does missions together just
as the report stated some are going to
go out and some are going to stay and
study and the lineup is quite good and a
little bit unexpected but that's what
Kevin Feige is going to want to do he's
going to bring in some of the
lesser-known
x-men and bring them to the big screen
and some of the bigger ones are
unfortunately going to take a seat back
for a little bit so the Fox x-men films
can die down for example another report
from Mikey Sutton says that magneto will
eventually come and be the villain but
also will eventually go on to lead the
x-men against Doctor Doom but in this
report he does state that this is going
to be several several years down the
road most likely not until the next
Avengers in game level event and that's
because most of the movies that Fox did
concerning the x-men had magneto in it
his character and other main characters
need to cool down a bit until they come
into the MCU
however they are keeping characters like
Cyclops Nightcrawler and a storm and
storm is the second thing that this
report talks about
that is really really big because her
story is going to tie the MCU together
in a really big way this report says
that storm is going to be from what
Conda this is something that many many
people have been expecting for a while I
myself have done a few videos on this
and that is because of the relationship
between storm and T'Challa aka Black
Panther they have a very long history
together in the comics and their story
actually leads up to the Avengers vs.
x-men Black Panther and storm or to
chala and Ororo both actually meet when
they are young in fact their children
when they meet for the very first time
Aurora was in Cairo and her parents were
killed which left her alone wandering
the desert she eventually decides to go
back to her mother's homeland in Kenya
but while on her travels she comes
across to Chawla who was being kidnapped
at the time using her weather
controlling powers she rescues him the
two of them hit it off and have instant
chemistry becoming friends and a little
bit more now eventually they would grow
up and black panther would go on to join
the Avengers and storm would go on to
join the x-men after going separate ways
their lives kept them busy but they
would bump into each other here and
there and so eventually black panther
decided that it was time for them to get
married in 2006 in Black Panther vol 4
number 14 and 15 - chala took to a knee
and proposed to storm now storm resisted
at first expressing her heartbreak from
them being separated as kids but
ultimately would agree and the two of
them would go on to get married now this
is the extremely important part to the
MCU and here's why the wedding was an
extremely big deal at the time in the
comics they actually got married during
the Civil War ceasefire event but it was
such a big deal that the x-men the
Avengers and the Fantastic Four all
showed up even though they were at odds
with each other everyone agreed to put
it behind them and be peaceful for the
wedding it was such a big deal that The
Watcher himself even showed up to watch
them get married this could be an event
in which we see the Avengers the x-men
and the Fantastic Four all together for
the very first time in the MCU
now I know a lot of people are asking
well what about Nakia from black panther
well we didn't see Nakia and Avengers
infinity war or Avengers endgame and at
the time when Black Panther came
Mount Marvel actually didn't own the
rights to the Fox x-men characters yet
but they do now and now that they do
they might have different plans for
black panther Nakia may show up again
but also she may be gone and storm could
come into play and it sounds like that's
what's going to happen however in the
comics they would eventually go on to
get a divorce and this divorce was a
pretty big deal because it was caused by
the avengers versus the x-men five of
the x-men including Namor would get
possessed by the Phoenix force and while
possessed by the Phoenix force Namor
practically destroyed Wakanda now since
storm was an x-men during this event she
sided with the x-men after Wakanda was
destroyed she returned to Wakanda to
tell jacala that she was sorry but he
told her that he annulled the wedding
and he was no longer her husband now
this is a big deal because there's been
reports that the ultimate goal for the
x-men entering the MCU is going to be an
Avengers vs. x-men film and if marbles
planning on going even just a little bit
with this story storm being in the MCU
is going to be a very big deal and it
sounds like she's going to be part of
the original MCU x-men team now the
third thing that's very important to
talk about is Weapon X now Weapon X
refers to a program the Super Soldier
program but also Wolverine Weapon X
weapon tin is Wolverine now you may have
caught my video that I did not too long
ago about the Weapon X program the
Weapon X program has actually been in
the MCU for a very long time it's just
had many different names Weapon X weapon
plus they're both interchangeable but
what it really is is the super soldier
program Wolverine is Weapon 10 Captain
America was weapon number one he was the
first experiment for the program and the
Incredible Hulk
Thunderbolt Ross said that he basically
restarted the weapons Plus program and
that's what he's going to be doing in
phase four when we start off with Black
Widow leading into the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier Thunderbolt Ross is going
to be looking for new serum we know that
he's going to be looking for the serum
in Black Widow and then in the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier we know that the
new Captain America is going to be given
a new super soldier serum but the new
serum that US agent John Walker is going
to be given is going to be used to
control his mind and this is
what the Weapon X program is going to do
create essentially super soldiers super
people and be able to control them now
since we have a Weapon X program that
means that Wolverine is going to be a
part of that program according to this
report which probably means that
Wolverine has been in the MCU for some
time now he's been a project and
experiment of the Weapon X program again
Captain America was weapon number one
and it's been many many years since
Captain America the First Avenger there
are definitely more than 10 Weapon X
experiments already in the MCU
and fun fact Deadpool is part of the
Weapon X program as well and right now
of course we know that Marvel is working
on another Deadpool film so according to
this report we are getting the x-men in
the MCU soon with a new lineup
Wolverine of course eventually making
his way and Deadpool of course
eventually but what do you think about
this report what do you think about the
new lineup what do you think about storm
being from Wakanda and do you think
she's going to have a relationship with
Black Panther and what do you think
about Wolverine coming in with the
Weapon X program let me know what you
think about all of this and the comments
down below don't forget to like this
video and subscribe to stay up-to-date
on everything relating to the MCU for
live updates you can follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof